trong tụi tình thống nhìn, tây nhiều năm trước khi mà hệ thống hệ 2,
ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra có đến cái chuyện gái của các cái chuyện gia về việc tính được
vui trong thế điều trị tụi tình thống nhìn mà cũng thảy là trong cái quá trình
trọn học thôi, những những chúng ta cũng cần hảy danh cũng cần nhiều mạng
chứ, ra đặc biệt là trong tụi tình thống nhìn, liên qua đến chào tự
tựu đing qua em bẽ nhưng hình này thì ai đã bọt tạo ở dùng trong
các cái công nghệ của lá, và mà cũng làm một cái phương tị mà có thể
ở dạy sắt định đuối kế phương mình có khơ
là ngoài chỉ chỉ chúng ta sắt định mặng mám chương
tạy sặt định và chiếc nhiィển và mạng
trong tạy kế dụi tụi tụi tụi tụi tụi
hảy thống về ai cũng làm một cái hảy thống
tụi tụi tụi tụi tụi tụi tụi xe tụi tụi tụi
nhìn được cái phương ra sặt định đuối kế phương
tụi tụi khơ, hề vãi
hí vọng ra là cái triệu tụi tụi tụi này sei nem bài
cái trao này thống vào hư, chông được chị